this is a toilet
this is also a toilet so this
and this
is the crumbling infrastructure
underneath in the u.s and other places
the wastewater infrastructure is aging
and it's not very well suited for
dealing with a lot of the challenges the
future this is chelsea wald she spent
over eight years researching the toilet
and discovered it needs a big upgrade
[Music]
why hasn't the toilet really changed one
of the reasons is technological lock-in
our predecessor spent lots of money
putting these pipes in the ground and
then we're also kind of psychologically
locked into it it's hard for us to
imagine something different
technologists are redesigning the toilet
to do more than what we've asked of it
before previous societies um knew that
pee and poo were valuable resources in
terms of the nutrients in them the
current sewage system
makes it difficult to
recover that but it would be a lot
easier if we could do it at the toilet
level rather than waiting for all the
mixing to happen and then trying to get
it all out at the end one thing that
i've seen here in the netherlands are
piloting of vacuum toilets these use
very little water and
they suck out the waste and keep it
separate from other household wastewater
the gray water coming out of the house
and that makes it possible to make
better use of that waste another
innovation that i've seen that's
promising is urine diversion toilets so
toilets that actually separate pee and
poo these have been very hard to develop
to design because they are awkward to
use there's a new design
called the urine trap that does this
separation a little more seamlessly with
less trouble to the user so the
high-tech toilet of the future might be
a toilet
that has medical
capabilities i talked to one innovator
who has made a toilet that actually
images your poop is and from that can
determine some things about your health
and especially over time and to alert
you if there might be a problem
the first big comprehensive sewer system
for removing human waste from a city was
in london
in the 19th century some of those
original sewers around the world from
the 19th early 20th century are still in
the ground and still
operating one big problem from some of
those old sewers it's they were combined
sewers so they combined storm water
with all this household water when
there's a storm even if it rains a
little bit in some places the sewers
overflow there's a couple of ways that
cities are dealing with this it's a very
very difficult problem some are digging
big tunnels it's very expensive massive
storage underground some are building
green infrastructure above ground to
absorb a lot of that storm water so it
doesn't even go into the store and then
some cities are making their sewers
smarter south bend indiana have a
combined sewer and they've started
putting these you know movable devices
remote devices into their sewers and
they've been able to reduce the number
of overflows a lot without actually
having to dig any extra
tunnels while some cities are making
sewers smarter other cities are
reimagining the sewer as an energy
source in vancouver a sustainable energy
system was used to heat the city's
olympic village you can also start to
harvest stuff from sewers kind of works
like the reverse of a refrigerator uses
a fluid to
to capture the heat and then that heat
can then be transferred into a
distribution system to run through the
building just like any other heating
system from the perspective of someone
in the building they would never know
that the source of the heat was sewage
many cities already have a big mix of
sanitation technologies that diversity
can actually make cities more resilient
in a way so if you can say as a city
grows instead of expanding the sewer
system it might make sense instead to
introduce building scale systems or
district scale systems or if there are
areas where it really makes sense to
have on-site sanitation because it's
kind of more rural you could introduce
systems there that make sense you know
ecologically for that area
wastewater treatment plants take
everything we dump down the drain and
toilet filters it and uses
microorganisms to clean the water one of
the problems that wastewater treatment
plants face is the residual sludge that
comes out of this process but there's
people who are now looking for new ways
to make use of this sludge one is to
take that sludge and turn it into a kind
of bio crude that can then be used as a
transportation fuel in a lot of places
people have been inadvertently drinking
recycled reused waste water for a long
time so these programs are called
indirect potable reuse programs orange
county was the pioneer of this program
they actually clean their water to
drinking water standards using advanced
technology and then they inject it into
an aquifer and then on the other hand
you have direct potable reuse
and that would mean taking the cleaned
up effluent
and putting it back into the pipeline
directly as drinking water there is a
fear of the yuck factor or the ick
factor which has held back these
programs in the past there is a big
trend for pilot projects for direct
potable reuse all over the world but
especially in the united states even in
the last year
or two it's just going to be one of the
most reliable sources of water that's
available and you'd rather have direct
potable reuse water than no water coming
from your tap that's for sure
so when writing this book i came across
just a wide variety of people
working on all different aspects of the
toilet from the design of public toilets
to
the
design of the toilet bowl to
improving sewer systems to improving the
pit latrines to improving wastewater
treatment to using the products of
wastewater treatment the toilet is
really one of the most fundamental
technologies that underpin human society
and if you want to think about it
poetically we are connected to each
other as humans and to the planet
through the toilet so it is so important
that our toilets are good that they're
healthy that they're sustainable and
that everybody has access to one
[Music]